تغيير نظام التقاعد الفرنسي رفع سن
التقاعد من 62 الى 64 عاما
جاء في ظل ازمه يعيشها صندوق التقاعد قد
تصل الى 17 مليار يورو بحلول 2005
تظاهر الملايين من الفرنسيين ضد هذا
القانون خلال الشهور الاخيره
البرلمان الفرنسي لم يدعم المشروع وخاصه
احزاب اليسار
رئيسه الوزراء اليزابيث مررت القانون
باستخدام بند في الدستور معروف تحت رقم 49
ثلاثه
الشارع الفرنسي رد على القرار الحكومي
باضرابات في قطاعات حيويه
وبمظاهرات اكبر تخللت بعضها اعمال عنف
شاركت في التظاهرات قطاعات التعليم
والنظافه والنفط والنقل الجوي والبري
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات